Speaker 1: Let's go next to Blake
from Seattle. Blake, welcome.
Blake from Seattle. You are on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, you can hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Hey, I was just
wondering. I kind of wanted to run something
by you when it comes to taxing the rich.
Okay. I wanted to know if it would be a good idea
to tax like the rich on the loans that they get.
Sorry, I'm kind of nervous. No, you.
Speaker 1: Do have bank, so let me see if I
understand the question. You're saying, like, for.
Let me let me explain it and we'll see if I'm on
the right track here. Blake okay.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: So a mechanism that sometimes
the wealthy use is they have all of these
stocks and bonds. If they sell the stocks
and bonds and there's been appreciation,
they owe capital gains. So what you can do is get
like a pledged asset loan or otherwise take a loan
against those stocks and bonds. So you say, hey,
I've got 10 million in stock. Give me a $5 million
loan. I'll give you the stock as collateral. The
5 million loan doesn't count as income. And then
you just spend the 5 million and you're sort of
avoiding the taxes, at least while you're alive.
That's kind of what you're suggesting, right?
Speaker 3: Yeah. So I was saying like, I'm saying,
like, maybe there's like a threshold. So like a
normal person can get, like, a normal loan without
being taxed for. Right. But, like, the super
rich would have to pay taxes on it. And then
I don't care if, like, in the end, they want
to, you know, write it off on their taxes as
like the 5 million that they borrowed. Even if
the stock depreciates and they have to pay the
rest of the capital gains when they're selling.
But I feel like that would prevent more of the
rich, super rich people from like, avoiding taxes.
Speaker 1: Yup. I mean, listen, you're thinking
along the same lines that we recently did an
interview with an inequality economist who said
similar a similar idea is let's tax the rich when
their money is just sitting in order to, you know,
kind of influence them to put the money into the
economy in some kind of more stimulative way.
I think these are all totally reasonable
ideas. And Blake, I think it's great that
you're thinking about it. The changes that
would be took it just like I never say never,
but the the degree of changes to the way
the tax code works in order to do that,
that's far more complicated than like changing
the top tax rate or the capital gains rate. So
I don't want to say it'll never happen,
but it'll probably never happen because
that's just not the way loan proceeds work.
Speaker 3: Yeah. It's unfortunate because I
feel like that would solve a lot of a lot of the
problems and it would prevent that whole wealth
tax thing from people who feel like that's unfair.
Speaker 1: Yep, absolutely. Now you're thinking
about no right lines. There's
just there's economic realities
and there's political realities.
Speaker 3: Yeah. All right. Well,
thanks, David. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. Blake from Seattle.
Very good call. We're going to take a very
short break. If you're hanging on to talk to me,
just keep holding because I'm going
right back to the phones in a moment.